researchers have come up with a new 3d
printing technology that makes objects
appear all at once seemingly from
nowhere the new approach is built on
technology for pinpoint delivery of
radiation and cancer patients the
researchers used a computer-controlled
digital light projector to cast images
through a rotating clear container
holding a photosensitive gel the
projected images are based on a scan of
a 3d object as the container rotates
photons entering from different angles
meet at select spots in the gel where
they meet their combined energy
solidifies the gel where photons don't
combine with enough energy they pass on
through without altering the material
the approach is fast able to create
complex objects such as a centimeter
sized copy of the thinker in just
minutes it can also create 3d plastic
parts around existing objects such as a
plastic handle around a metal
screwdriver shaft so while this device
may not print Earl Grey tea hot
on-demand it does induce some of the
same sense of wonder
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]